[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday the 21st of
october
i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and your host this week
on this week's show we'll discuss the
goings-on in westminster with the
spectators political team james forsyth
and katie balls it's less than two weeks
until cop 26 and the government is
eyeing up your gas boiler what exactly
is the cost of achieving net zero the
climate change committee's chris stark
debates conservative mp bob seeley
across the channel the french elections
are gearing up and macron's biggest
threat is in fact a journalist who
hasn't even declared his candidacy
i'll talk to the spectator's deputy
editor freddie gray and our contributor
jonathan miller about the growing
intrigue around eriksen more
lionel shriver will also join the show
to discuss the best way to deal with
people trying to cancel you in light of
what's happened to the american stand-up
comic dave chappelle
and i'll speak to melanie mcdonough
about our modern dependence on mobile
phones
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator tv you should subscribe to our
youtube channel just click the red
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
and why not subscribe to the spectator
magazine too you can get 12 weeks of the
magazine and a free 20 pound amazon
voucher for just 12 pounds to take up
the deal go to spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv
first up let's take a look at what's
happening in the world of politics i'm
joined now by james forsyth and katie
balls welcome back to spectator tv both
to start with you katie covid i'm sorry
to say is once again a big topic in
westminster after a month or two of it
taking a back seat to other issues the
health secretary sachit javid gave a
covet press conference yesterday where
he didn't trigger plan b which includes
the return of masks and possibly vaccine
passports but he did issue some stark
warnings talk us through it
so sergey java's message was we're not
getting any new restrictions yet but i
think implicitly or between the lines
who are saying if you refuse to get your
booster jabs if you still haven't been
jabbed
in the first place and you don't come
forward that's when you might start to
have to bring things in uh you know
ahead of christmas so while that was
clear the government does not want to
move to its plan b i think there is a
sense that it's not been ruled out
entirely and we're also hearing reports
if you uh you know look at various ways
of papers are covering this that the
cabinet office is considering a plan c
uh number tenno said it's uh completely
wrong to suggest they are considering it
but the idea is that plans are being
drawn up say plan b wasn't enough so i
think we're back in the territory of
coburg being to dominate the news again
those debates between the scientists and
the politicians playing out this type
nhs chiefs warning that action needs to
be taken
and for now the government is holding
tight um but they're going to come under
more pressure if the case numbers
continue to go up and that impacts
hospitalizations and deaths
james some of our viewers will
understandably be slightly confused that
the narrative has returned to get your
jab or freedom may be taken away because
vaccine takeup broadly speaking in the
uk has been very good well over 90
percent of adults are estimated to have
antibodies and based on the data we
currently have the vaccines are working
significantly weakening the link between
infection and severe illness so why are
these calls from some for restrictions
to return so loud
i think the worry is about waning
immunity that
the data from israel suggests that over
time the vaccines become marginally less
effective now the the drop in efficacy
isn't huge but you replicate that drop
in efficacy across the entire most
vulnerable cohort and you have a problem
especially because we have a health
service which which uh its efficiency is
that it runs at very near to capacity
all the time you know i mean a winter
crisis is not an unusual thing in the
nhs and so i think there is that concern
uh and i think the other concern is that
you are not seeing the the public are
they not not coming forward for their
boosters but people aren't jumping with
the alacrity that they did first time
round
i think one of the big questions here is
you know one of the reasons the
government has changed its tone so
dramatically
is uh if you basically tell people that
kobit is serious still that it isn't
over yet will that prompt more people to
to go and get their booster shots more
people to urge their 12 to 15 year old
kids to get vaccinated and then i think
the second thing which is an intriguing
question is how self-regulating will the
public's behavior be you know uh we for
example freedom day uh i think in the
week after freedom day travel on london
transport actually declined rather than
increase because people were very
worried about high case numbers and so
decided to to stay home minimize their
social contacts to reduce their shot now
this is the crucial question were they
doing that to reduce their chances of
infection or were they doing that
because they were very worried about the
so-called pandemic that um they would
they would become in contact with
someone who was positive and have to
isolate for 10 days
that
requirement has now lifted and i think
the big question is we will find out how
self-regulating the public's behavior is
uh when you when people are not so
worried about getting pinged by test and
trace
now katie it's been almost a week since
sir david amos was murdered
what has the mood been like in
westminster rmp is demanding more
protection
so the mood in parliament is somber i
think lots of mps are still coming to
terms of what happened last week
we had a debate on monday which actually
was a
approaching warm debate lots of nice
anecdotes about um
colleagues memories of sir david amos um
but i think now obviously the
conversation has moved to how you can
prevent uh something like this happening
in the future i think the more that
debate goes on the more it's clear there
is no simple solution so we've been
hearing calls for david's law this is
the idea of cracking down on social
media companies on anonymous you know
troll accounts to prevent harassment
there's also the home secretary talking
about security for mps in their
surgeries and so it would mean if some
were to come there causing harm there
would be security on the premises um but
i think all these things might help a
little bit
but
what happens when an mp leaves the
surgery in a constituency they're very
visible and everyone will know who they
are so i think that we're starting to
see that while there are steps you can
take that might offer some assurance
there's nothing
really at the moment which appears to
solve the problem completely
and this is a major issue isn't it james
you write in your political column this
week that options are being floated as
to what can be done to prevent future
attacks but it doesn't seem like there
are any easy options
no everything involves trade-offs i
think one idea that as casey said is
gaining popularity is it's gonna be
banning anonymous accounts online you
had mark francois a friend of damien
amis suggesting that in the commons
debate on monday today matt hancock a
former um digital minister and the
labour mp rupert hutch has written a
piece of the time saying that online
anonymity needs to be tackled by the
online harms bill but i think mp should
step back here i think there are there
are some real dangers to ending online
anonymity which is uh not least of which
is the kind of international dimension i
think if the uk decided to end online
anonymity while either by banning
anonymous accounts outright or requiring
platforms to know who the ultimate hold
of the anonymous account is i think that
example would be seized on by
authoritarian regimes around the world
to justify clamp downs on on internet
freedom so i think mp should trade very
carefully before but they go down this
route i don't i don't think it is a
sensible response right now lastly while
i have you both here i want to get your
quick thoughts on the government's
announcements this week on its strategy
to tackle climate change
james there's a row over gas boilers as
the government sets out a 5 000 subsidy
for roughly 90 000 households for heat
pump replacements what's the mood in the
tory party like since all these
announcements have been made so i i
think that these announcements have not
been to to use the phrase in the energy
mix
the response has not been as nuclear as
some might have expected
i think because the plans are
uh
not that specific and it's also not
clear that gas boilers will be outlawed
at any point is it just it's the aim is
that they wouldn't that is that people
wouldn't be purchasing them after this
point
i don't think you've seen as
furious a response from some of the tory
mps more skeptical of net zero than you
might than you might have expected if
this had been a a more draconian policy
but i think that i think these debates
about the cost of net zero about the
right energy mix in the transition
aren't going to go away and they're
obviously complicated by the current uh
energy crunch at the moment i think one
of the big things that you will see is a
renewed push for nuclear and people
arguing that the government should go
much further and much faster on these
small modular reactors and that this is
this is a way of both guaranteeing
energy ensuring security of supply and
you know the argument is coming i think
the government should accept this that
you know you need to treat nuclear as a
green form of energy
katie these strategy documents on how
we're going to achieve net zero have
been released in the lead up to cop26
which is now just around the corner uh
of course in addition to these documents
we also have the treasury's net zero
review which didn't put a final price
tag on how much net zero is going to
cost but it's quite clear from the
document that it is going to be a pricey
endeavor do you think we're going to see
increasing discomfort from tory mps in
the coming weeks about how much this is
going to cost
or are they going to rally behind the
prime minister as he goes into cop26 and
presents his strategy on the world stage
so i think we've seen these documents so
even that treasury document it
did
suggest that this is going to be a very
expensive endeavor and when it comes to
plugging the gap from fuel duty if you
move to electric cars
when it comes to
you know going further with certain
measures if you don't get some amounts
of industry it could well lead to either
cuts on public spending in other places
or tax risers so there's quite a clear
outline there but yet as you say there's
no final figure on how much net zero is
going to cost and i think that is in
part because
in a way we don't know what the
technology is going to be in a few years
time and also the government doesn't go
near that and we're also hearing that um
the treasury cost analysis was perhaps
slightly watered down uh in its redrafts
because number 10 are nervous about a
backlash so i think in these green
documents we've had this week although
you do have tory mps many of them i
would say the usual suspect sounding
alarm there's enough of a fudge going on
that it you're not going enough into
specifics i think number 10 have
purposely tried to try this middle path
where they're talking about their aims
when you scratch the surface there's
nothing that definite you don't really
at the moment have to get rid of your
boiler by the day even if you're really
supposed to um to to manage to avoid a
big blow up ahead of cop 26. i think in
terms of the summit in glasgow we're not
actually expecting many mps to be there
so it's more going to be ministers
involved in the foreign secretary the
prime minister of course the prime
minister's net zero champion so everyone
who's there is going to be very on
message
and i think the question is can you get
an international agreement which moves
thing a lot along or do you end up in a
situation where
countries like china we know president
xi is not going vladimir putin's not
going so russia china
do not play along in which case i think
domestically this stuff becomes a much
harder sell perhaps not immediately but
just over time because it looks so the
uk is potentially putting the cost on
consumers at a time when other voters
around the world other citizens are not
having to
james and katie thanks for joining me
let's stay on the topic of cop 26 the
cost of achieving net zero while still
vague are clearly big this week the
government announced some support to a 5
000 pound subsidy for 90 000 households
to replace their gas boilers with heat
pumps but the average cost of a heat
bump currently is around 10 000 pounds
that's just one aspect of going green
is this strategy fully thought through
i'm joined now by chris stark chief
executive of the climate change
committee and bob seely the conservative
mp for the isle of wight
hi both thanks so much for joining me
chris to start with give us your
reaction to the government's
announcements this week
well we're 24 hours after the doc the
government dropped nearly 2 000 pages on
us so it's a huge amount of material to
process so i think i can only really
give you my early reaction to it but i
think broadly it's good um the
government has has been tasked with
setting out a plan for reaching net zero
and if you look what they've published
it's hard to say that they have failed
in that task they've clearly laid out a
detailed prescription in every area i
think the test for us will be the extent
to which the policies that are in that
plan will deliver against the ambitions
but the ambitions now i think are
broadly in the right place so that's
very exciting
bob i'm sure you've been making your way
through the many documents as well
what's your initial take
well like like chris i'm i'm sort of
doing my best to speed read them and i
start with the executive summaries and
then sort of move from there into
various topics
i give the government its credit it's
trying to set noble goals it's trying to
do the right things uh and zero carbon
is is a great ambition uh i i'm not sure
i would quite go
as far as chris to
to say that the ambition is is right
because i
i think like a lot of people i'm
slightly wary of some of the things that
we're doing on the way to having
hopefully zero emissions at 2050 or at
some point relatively soon afterwards
and my concern is is not with the
government's intent because it's arts in
the right place and i think boris says
the prime minister had a very strong
leadership on this but
our ability to deliver and our ability
to effectively align common sense with
some of these policies because i i think
some of us are not just myself have
concerns about that and my i suppose the
political fear is that we are going to
confront a reality where we can't
deliver on this stuff it's going to get
very expensive and it's going to get
very politically unpopular
well chris what about one of those areas
of contention gas boilers seem to be on
the way out and we know that this tried
and tested and cheap form of of heating
our homes
is carbon admitting um but is the
alternative feasible anytime soon only
last month you were saying that heat
pumps are not yet ready for mass market
yeah i did say that and i stand by that
because at the time what i was referring
to is the fact that they are expensive
they're expensive there isn't an
installer community
of any great size in this country
and we haven't done it at scale now if
you look across the water in a place
like germany they're doing a million a
year
with similar climate not the same
climate but a similar climate they'll
have a different housing stock but their
own challenges there but
we see around the world that heat pumps
are a viable technology
so i think we are about to enter the
mainstream for heat pumps and i think
what the government has done this week
is is is hasten that
by firstly by offering some incentive
financial incentive for a relatively
small number of heat pumps to be
installed but crucially to make it clear
that by the mid-2030s they are aiming to
phase out the sale of gas spoilers which
gives us i suppose the market gives the
market a a trajectory now over the next
10 years or so to prepare
for that moment what we're not clear on
yet although there's some intriguing
stuff in the um in the pa in the
documents that have been published by
the government in the last few few days
is quite how we get from where we are
today which is about 30 000 heat pump
installations a year to where the
government wants to be by the end of
this decade which is somewhere between
six hundred thousand and a million heat
pumps a year
uh and it's interesting that there's a
there is one policy that they didn't
make much of yesterday which is this
obligation
uh that they would they would like to
put on the manufacturers of boilers
to raise over time the proportion of
heat pumps that are being sold in the uk
as a proportion of the total heat
installations that the uk
makes each year now that is a policy
that could really work we've seen that
work in for example uh california when
it comes to zero emission vehicles a
mandate they call it mandate for sales
there's a mandate for uh zero emission
vehicles as part of the package of
things that was announced yesterday so
that idea of mandates seems to be back
in fashion with the government i suppose
that might be one way in which we can
see that that large and very rapid scale
up that we would need over the next
decade and beyond
that's an interesting point chris
because there's been a lot of criticism
of the five thousand pound subsidy to
upgrade your boiler people saying well
that's not gonna cover it especially for
low-income households and the subsidies
only estimated to reach about 90 000
households and we're going to need it to
we're going to need these upgrades to
reach millions more but you are saying
that the timeline is actually for the
market it's so that companies know where
the government's planning on going and
hopefully that brings with it innovation
brings costs down but there's no
guarantee
no there isn't a guarantee and i think
that's a reasonable uh outlook on it and
and a reasonable point for you to make
uh the the scale-up that's required is
enormous i don't think we can escape
that you know the the the need to get to
something of the order of a million low
carbon heat installations per year uh by
the time we get into the 2030s from
where we are now is a huge task but it
was interesting i suppose in the in the
things that the government said
yesterday
you can see a fairly clear plan to put
the obligation on business on the on the
on the commercial
operators in that sector to try and
deliver against these targets and that
that should put the incentives in the
right place to bring down the cost for
the consumer you're absolutely right the
5 000 pounds per heat pump isn't really
going to touch the sides
of this challenge overall but it's a
nice way to start over the next three
years so that should
make some headway i suppose and i can
see that that policy having an impact in
the overall mission that the government
has set of bringing heat pumps down to
cost parity with gas boilers and already
we've seen a response from some of the
the the commercial operators notably
octopus energy who've stepped up to say
that they think that that can be
delivered even more quickly than 2030
which is the government's plan overall
so we may see now a race to install heat
pumps at a cheaper price for the
consumer and crucially
the kind of supply chain skilled supply
chain that we would need building up
alongside that i think that is actually
the bigger challenge is is how you build
the installer community to the size that
we'd need it to achieve the the goals
that the uk has set
bob the prime minister's rhetoric seems
have changed actually quite a bit in
recent weeks more acknowledgement that
this net zero target is going to need to
be seen through the prism of working for
the consumer and working for the
taxpayer and the government's actually
very lucky that um you know we're not
having the debates that we were having
15 20 years ago when i was a kid about
whether or not climate change exists the
question now is how exactly we go about
handling it and what the target is and
how soon it should come in and what the
costs are going to be
broadly speaking the public is on the
government side on the left and the
right voters care about climate change
but i guess my question to you is seeing
as the government's already been willing
to break certain manifesto promises to
increase taxes in areas that the public
consider important like the nhs
is the government going to be more
honest about the fact that you know
these changes come with a price tag and
actually taxes may have to go up again
in order to combat climate change um the
simple answer is as we can see from the
debate that's happening in the
newspapers i think the government is
divided on that and i think the treasury
is more concerned with uh more concerned
about this and other government
departments i think for me look it might
well be that when it comes to heat pumps
the the green energy schemes have quite
often failed in the past or the green
home scheme was not a success so
government schemes can still fail
what could well happen with heat pumps
is what happened with wind turbines that
when actually the market kicked in and
could produce economies of scale
actually the wind turbines have done
extremely well and it might be that in
10 years time there will be as chris
hopes and i hope there's going to be a
wide availability of heat pumps that
will be more efficient now because they
don't work for all homes um they're not
as efficient by a long way as
as boilers and if you have to rip out
all your piping because your piping is
wrong for the enlarged radiators you're
going to need
there are a lot of complicating factors
here my worry is just i think we have to
we're losing a sense of perspective the
united kingdom is responsible for one
percent of emissions and yet somehow
we're told that because we have historic
responsibility because the industrial
revolution started here that we have a
responsibility to go further faster than
other people
i'm sorry i just don't buy that argument
we if you got rid of every bit of carbon
that we emitted in this country you'd go
down from 100 percent to 99
and as long as countries like china are
emitting 30 percent uh
are responsible for 30 of emissions a
year i just think we've got to pres got
to have a sense of proportion and we've
got to drop some of the sort of
quasi-religious further by with which
we're approaching this issue we could
decarbonize completely it is not going
to save the planet so we have to have a
sense of realism about what we can do
and how we go about it one other example
came the government turned down of the
committee responsible to turn down the
jackdaw shells development of the
jackdaw field uh in the north sea we are
hoovering up natural gas from other
suppliers germany is entirely well
largely dependent 30 between 30 and 50
percent depending on the figures
depending on the type of fuel from
russia you know it is better for us
even if we're still admitting to be
producing our own gas and potentially
supplying europe then have the
environmental and frankly security
hazard of that gas coming from other
states that frankly care much less about
climate change than we do
chris
goss there's a lot to say about that i
mean i i think you're entirely right to
say that we are a small proportion of
global emissions but i think the the
idea of net zero is a fairly fundamental
one it's important to say that the
science says very clearly now that
globally we have to get to net zero or
we will keep warming the planet and
actually in recent years the science has
become even clearer on that including
notably the report from the ipcc in the
last few weeks now i suppose the point
here is that uh there is an argument to
say that there's a historical legacy and
that the uk
should address that with an early date
for net zero but it's not the argument i
would make i mean i think the argument
for net zero is that since the world is
on that journey there are
huge economic benefits to it so actually
setting that target and then and then
aiming for it it will create the new
kind of markets the new industries that
will be benefits to the people living in
this country and
in this transition and i think that's
the argument the government has made in
the net zero strategy that we saw
published yesterday it's also the
argument that china and others seem to
have accepted by wanting to supply into
that market now
china is one of the countries that has
set a net zero goal for 2060 as has the
us as has the eu so there is another
argument here about the trading bloc
that's within that net zero goal and we
are definitely in it and amongst the
lead of it and maybe the last thing i'll
say is on energy security of course net
zero itself buys the uk much greater
energy security
by being dependent on the very plentiful
electricity supplies that we can have
from renewables we will be more energy
secure and nuclear in that mix too so we
are a lot less exposed
to the kind of imported price
fluctuations imported fossil fuels that
we that we are exposed to at the moment
i'm sorry chris just with great respect
to you on that last point for example
that is only true in 20 or 30 years time
provided we actually grip
you know the modular nuclear reactors
and build a lot of them provided we
increase wind power provided we do stuff
like invest in tidal wave power so you
know power from from from from waves
rather than lagoons but actually for the
next decade for the next potentially 20
years we are giving up energy security
you look at germany and i'm i'm in with
you in spirit but it's just about
getting there and actually having common
sense here if you look at germany they
have given up they're shutting the what
the last of their 17 nuclear power
stations next year they are importing
and using their own lignite brown coal
they've gone from being the clean man of
europe to the dirtiest man in europe
they are effectively paying for russian
rearmament
potentially for russia to reinvade
ukraine or to try to invade ukraine
again in the next year or next five ten
years and because we are becoming
increasingly dependent on gas fields
outside the uk
we are actually undermining our security
including our energy resilience and our
energy security because we're not
continuing to invest in our own gas
fields it's the same argument chris that
i could make about the idiocy
of offshoring your manufacturing to
china and then claiming we're becoming
greener half hour emissions as you well
know have come from well out of our
emission cuts half have come from
shutting down coal-fired power stations
a very good idea provided we have
replacements half have come because
we've just outsourced our industry to
china and generally and and to other
countries in that neck of the woods and
they are going to decarbonize much more
slowly than us so this whole process of
virtue signaling and almost narcissistic
sort of virtue signaling about our own
moral purity is actually coming at the
expense of making a potentially
adversarial state a richer and b
making the world dirtier because
they are not taking the same attitude to
climate change as we do so when you say
our security we're better off we are in
20 or 30 years time for the next decade
for the next 15 20 years we're actually
endangering our security as well as
exporting jobs to other countries and
potentially adversarial states it is a
policy that could have been written by
the russians and the chinese rather than
whitehall
chris i want you to come back to any
point that bob made there and and have
your say um but i also want to ask you
about this short-term versus long-term
trade-off and the gains that are to be
made because we're in the midst now of
an energy crisis the cost of living
crisis is looming over so many people in
the uk and there's really no getting
around that and lots of people are
saying well nuclear can be the solution
in seven eight years time maybe ten
years time it can make the transition
much more comfortable but others are
saying well too little too late how is
that going to help us now
how do we get the balance right here
without having to roll back the progress
that has already been made in the uk in
trying to get to net zero while still
acknowledging that this is a very
difficult time for a lot of people who
would benefit from their bills going
down
well i mean there's again lots to say
about that i mean i think if
just as bob has acknowledged if we would
like to have the kind of energy security
that we will have in 20 years time
through the policy of approaching net
zero then we have to start on the
journey somehow i mean i think every
year we build out that that domestic
capacity
for generating the energy that we use
every year we get closer to that goal so
i would say that is as good a time as
any to start now the other point i would
make is that um we have indeed done a
lot by decarbonizing our power sector
we've also become much more energy
efficient as a sec as a as an economy
the outsourcing of of manufacturing
happened quite a long time ago now
actually you don't see that in the stats
um and in fact you know the gross value
we get from manufacturing has been has
been growing over time so so there is a
chance here to be decarbonized as a as a
as a country and to have decarbonized
industry but we can't just have that
overnight and we will need crucially
policy to drive some of that and to
protect british industry from the cost
of that decarbonization now i don't
think we conduct that that is a
major challenge that sits here it
relates to the other challenge that you
ask about about the cost of living
and i you know i'm not going to dress it
up there are costs in this transition i
think the aggregate position is a very
positive one we have a very large
investment to make as an economy but a
growing saving from those investments as
we decarbonize but this is a big
challenge for the government i i'm not
going to deny it and the answer that we
got from
the government yesterday in the net zero
strategy is that they want to put the
onus on
the on commerce and on business to bring
down the cost of this transition
alongside limited public spending to
protect those who can least afford it
from it from those costs and
it remains to be seen whether that
strategy will work
i'm quite interested to see what the
chancellor will say in his spending
review and his budget next week i think
that's the piece that we haven't yet
seen that sits alongside the net zero
statue but
it's it's a huge challenge i accept that
bob uh last question to you um to use
your words these virtue signaling
policies which you say could have been
designed in russia or china have indeed
come from your very own government so
are these the words that you would put
to your prime minister as well as to the
viewers on spectator tv
well i mean i'm fairly blunt speaking so
people can you know take it or leave it
i thank chris for his honesty in this
because these are noble ambitions and
nobody is doubting that but i just think
our desire to set an agenda and actually
deliver the reality of it is not coupled
up and chris is sort of he's saying that
he's got the honesty to say it's a thank
you to him because there is going to be
a big price
and if we we're not going to have that
threat from labor because their you know
their stance is going to be similar but
actually there are going to be a lot of
people in the country who are going to
be coming worse off because this is
going to cost our businesses and it's
going to cost people as well and and
that politicians have to get re-elected
and i can what my concern is that we
will start rowing back from these rather
than being more realistic now about for
example being able to the need to use
gas and to continue to invest in our own
gas fields so we can supply ourselves
and potentially europe whilst we build
the modular rolls-royce nuclear power
stations say no to the ridiculous
untrust untouched untested chinese
designs which we should never be have
been contemplating this takes time and
we need to be more honest and i think
because of cop and because we are um
you know for a variety of reasons we are
i i think we're just our ambitions and
our goals are getting ahead of the
reality and i think politically i worry
that we're going to pay a price for that
and i want very much i share chris's
goal and the goals of the prime minister
because i said and i manifest though
it's how we get there and having the
honesty to to confront some of these
bigger decisions but also keep investing
in gas in this country rather than
import it from much more unstable and
more unfriendly states
chris and bob thanks for joining us
next this week's cover story plan z
looks at an up-and-comer of french
politics a controversial journalist by
the name of eric zemor he's already
polling higher than marine le pen but
his critics accuse him of being a far
right candidate and often compare him to
donald trump
so who is zamor
freddie gray the spectator's deputy
editor pens this week's cover story and
he joins me now alongside jonathan
miller who writes about his amour rally
he attended last week
freddie tell us about eric samura who
hasn't even declared his candidacy yet
well it's a bit of a joke really that he
hasn't declared his candidacy because
everybody knows
uh that he's running and he appears to
have quite a sophisticated operation
behind him and the reason we at the
spectator know about this is because of
the the brilliant jonathan miller who's
about to start talking uh and he has
been on this story for the spectator
ahead of everyone which means that back
in march um we ran a piece
uh saying that he would be running and
to take him seriously as a possible
presidential candidate
and when jonathan first suggested it i
thought this seemed a little bit
eccentric and a little bit out there but
he's been proven
uh brilliantly right because zenmore is
emerging as a very serious presidential
candidate
and there's a lot of comparisons with
donald trump there are some good points
of comparison there
because the phenomenon is is quite real
and he's a very mediogenic personality
but he's also got a more serious streak
and as i try to say in the piece
um
and i'm not the first to make the
comparison but uh as i try and say in
the piece he's actually a bit more of a
boris johnson-like figure in my mind in
that he's a he's a first-rate mind he
writes his own books
um and he's a patriotic thinker who
seems to fail upwards hmm
well we'll come back to his ideology and
these comparisons certainly but first
jonathan as freddie says you've been
writing about zamor for the magazine for
months now he's a journalist term
politician you recently attended one of
his rallies what was it like
it was amazing i went down to bezier on
saturday night which is the
ancient winemaking capital of occitani
here in the south of france
to the zinger zanga theater
where i found
an hour and a half
before his
speech was even scheduled to begin
a vast crowd of people stretching around
the whole building
um
and i
took the opportunity from my training as
a
reporter to go around and talk to as
many of them as possible and i found an
almost fanatical degree of enthusiasm
for eric zamor who is this
you know piano black-footed uh so-called
algerian jew
in the heart of what was once national
front territory
inspiring
you know a couple of thousand locals
to show up and cheer him to the rafters
um
and he did he delivered a remarkable
speech
i think freddie's right that he's got
you know
this trumpian
ability to somehow
get people to
stamp their feet and clap their hands uh
with delight and he's got the kind of
the wit and the irritation of boris
yes some of that too
um
but i think he's also got um
an analysis that is playing very well
with the french who are disillusioned
with macron disillusioned with marine le
pen as her
as his preferred opposition and who are
looking for a
something fresh
i think they find his analysis
analysis of the social crisis
in france makes him a little like
douglas murray of our own parish
um who uh
you know and there are many points of
convergence between the strange death of
europe by
douglas and uh the suicide
francaise by uh
by zamor so there's some of that too
um and i wouldn't
hesitate from saying there's a there's a
little bit of thatcher in him or quite a
lot because he's he's a culture warrior
he
he um
his his view which he expresses
forcefully
is that the kind of woke groupthink
that is infesting our universities and
schools
public institutions public broadcasters
government
that
the it is the duty to go out and
confront that
um
intellectually
and for this he's been called a racist
and islamist as islamophobe
he's characterized continually as the
extreme right
by the bbc by the times by the guardian
by the new york times
he's a much more complex guy than that
but freddie these accusations have been
levied at him and with some backing he
has been convicted of inciting racial
hatred if brits have heard of them
they're likely to have heard of him as a
far right candidate so perhaps your
comparison to boris johnson or
jonathan's comparisons to the spectators
douglas murray wouldn't go down so well
with the people we've actually compared
him to
well
possibly not i'd say his his rhetoric is
more uh blunt than boris's perhaps but
he certainly he just like boris he has a
back catalogue of articles uh and books
uh that anybody could pore over and find
lots to be offended by he said a lot of
very provocative and shocking things but
we are now living in a slightly
different political moment i think now
where
politicians can succeed
not in spite but because they say uh
shocking and provocative things and it
makes people sit up and take notice and
it makes the media engage with them and
what's very interesting with
uh those sort of media reactions to the
more and particularly the foreign media
reactions as a more
uh foreign to france
uh is that they have this strange thing
of being angry about how interested they
are in him so you see a lot of articles
uh berating publications uh for showing
so much interest in him which is it's
quite a funny dynamic but it's how a lot
of populists succeed
um and it seems to be how zamor is
causing so much
uh aggravation and interest in this
presidential race jonathan on that point
zamor is now leading le pen in the polls
what is it about his ideology that's
winning out i think a lot of le pen
voters are aware that the le pen brand
has has
overrun its course her father
lost well i think five elections she's
lost two on the hop
she's kind of an idiot you know she was
eaten alive by
macron and the debates last time here
economic policies incoherent
she's attempted to make her party more
centrist but nobody believes it
um she's hopeless and she's lost
basically half her support since june
she's gone from you know 25 28
to 12 14 depending on the polls still i
mean you you might you might
fundamentally disagree with her i think
that she's gone about what she wants to
achieve the wrong way but i mean she to
say she's an idiot i mean she has been
quite influential in french politics
she's really put the pressure on no she
hasn't been she's just she's been very
convenient in french politics
for uh for ensuring
as the fifth republic was designed to
ensure that uh that you know the
moderate centrist
you know moderate writers gets in power
and this is how
and so she her
entire track record is one of failure
she you know then that the front
national
the the rasombra more national didn't
win a single region in france not one
in in the most recent regional elections
um
you know uh
even her militants even people i know
who have supported her in the past say
say you know aside from anything else
she's a loser but you know as for you
know the idiot charge i'm really happy
substantiating that you know i just
refer people to the videos of her debate
with macron where the her absolute
incoherence on the you know you know on
the future of europe um and and and
france's role in it uh was was was
he he he crushed her bones and made his
bread um and uh
she she's terrible on television
um i would add one thing to what freddie
said of what you know what we're waiting
for you know we're waiting to see if if
if uh if some more can attract the 500
uh sponsorships he needs to you know get
on the ballot willing to see if some
more can raise the 15 million or so
euros he needs you know to mount a
credible campaign and pay people
and we're also waiting to see
where he emerges
on
on on the really fundamental issue in
france which is uh the eu because in in
2005 the french voted by 55 percent not
to sign the constitution
um the government ignored them
uh and implemented it anyway calling it
the lisbon treaty and this is a fault
line in french politics which still
exists and on which i think zamor is
likely to find himself on the side of
those saying the 2005 um
referendum what he he's saying
the 2005 referendum needs to be rerun
now if he means it he's saying we can
reintroduce referendums into french
politics
and we're going to politicians are going
to have to trust the people to make
decisions
um this could be very very revolutionary
so maybe we're kind of one of those not
infrequent french
you know pre-revolutionary revolutionary
periods or maybe we're not i mean to be
to be realistic macron you know has
still got the the money he's still got
the media you know he's still got
control of the institutions
um
so he's still
the favorite but that zamor is is is
you know the the flavor of the month and
um
and we're on it
freddy as jonathan says there's more is
in no position to come in and sweep the
election macron is still comfortably in
the lead and zamor has the odds stacked
against him but let's take jonathan's
charge that le pen has been convenient
for french politics is the more the one
who's going to come in and really shake
things up
well i think it is hard to say i mean
his campaign is still embryonic it's his
the people behind it still call it a
pre-campaign
uh so it's it's yet to be born really
but i think
uh it clearly has a lot of momentum
behind it and a lot of interest and
enthusiasm
which is not something you can say
about marine le pen and and to repeat
marine le pen has always had the baggage
of her father and the baggage of her
name she's never quite been able to cast
that off
um zimmer does not have that and he will
be called
anti-semitic even even though he's
jewish he'll be called racist
uh he will be called a fascist and a
nazi
um and it may be that a lot of this will
stick to him because he has said so many
provocative things in the past
um but for now
it looks like he's got serious momentum
behind it freddie and jonathan thanks
for your time
another week another online controversy
this time the focus is on american comic
dave chappelle who makes jokes about the
trans community in his latest netflix
show it's led to a staff walkout at
netflix and the co-ceo of the company
has apologized for his handling of the
situation
what should you do when the online mob
comes after you in this week's magazine
lionel shriver shares her tips having
been subjected to a fair few attempted
cancellations herself she joins me now
thanks for joining spectator tv lionel
first can you tell us about dave
chappelle who is he and why is he in
trouble
he's a black comedian he's incredibly
popular i think for good reason he's
good at his job
he's american
and
he's done a series of specials for
netflix
the one before the one that's out now
the
previous one is called sticks and stones
was pretty hard on
the transgender community and
i think
said community if that's really what it
is uh is not accustomed to people
telling jokes about them
and they reacted very badly uh
so
dave chappelle got a reputation as a
trans vote
um
it in the latest special the closer
which was
recently released this month
um
he doubles down
so rather than decide that material got
him into trouble i'd better he'd better
avoid it
he
went even more
controversial on this stuff
and i don't have any objection to that
in fact i think strategically that's
pretty sound
because that means
you know you're saying that you're not
intimidated and you will tell jokes
about whomever you wish so
however my column is critical of his
special on
another front uh
also on the strategic front
and that is because i found the
performance quite defensive
in some ways he wants to have his cake
and eat it too
he wants
to be able to tell
really risque
potentially offensive jokes about trans
people and at the same time
he wants them to like him
um
i don't think you can i don't think you
can
have it both ways uh
and i think he just should have thrown
the caution to the winds and
gone ahead and
been as brutal as he wanted to
because he was not going to make these
people happy
it seems quite telling of our current
culture that
he felt that he had to have these
earnest moments signaling his support
for the trans community because they
almost are
showing that the other parts of his show
are indeed a joke he's having to make
very clear that he is joking whereas
perhaps in the past people would have
taken a joke even an offensive one to be
just that
yeah but when you're tuning into a
comedy special you wouldn't shouldn't
have to be told that this is this is a
joke this is supposed to be funny that
goes without saying
um
and he went you know there's a section
of the special where he goes very
earnest and it's long
uh telling uh the story of how
a trans comedian opened one of his acts
and
um then got all kinds of stick on social
media because she was supporting a
transphobe
and subsequently
she killed herself
um
[Music]
i mean it sounds like it's obviously
it's a sad story but
i don't it doesn't
belong in a stand-up routine it's not
funny it's not intended to be funny
it's intended to make
it clear that dave chappelle really
cares about trans people when he's not a
transphobe
and what i look at in the
column
is an interesting phenomenon
that
being defensive is deadly what makes
that interesting is well then what do
you do when somebody falsely accuses you
of something what else is there to do
but defend yourself
yet
being
classically defensive is a big strategic
mistake
and i examined a number of other
different
strategies rather than
being classically defensive
one of them is to be aggressive right
back
the other one is to
completely ignore your detractors i
think there's something to be said for
that most importantly i think is to keep
doing what you've been doing do not be
deterred
do not be way laid do not
let other people
uh
set your agenda
and that's basically what i try to do in
my column
uh
everyone who pays any attention anything
knows that
i have got it in the neck more than once
for
writing wrong think
now
i could take it on and defend myself
i've done that like once i didn't think
it worked very well
for me the best strategy has been
just keep doing what i've been doing
that is don't be deterred
i i write what i think to i try to
express it as clearly as i can
um
and i don't avoid subjects that are
going to get me into trouble as a as a
consequence you know i get into trouble
but so far i've survived and that's
partly due to the brave spectator
ted sarando the co-ceo of netflix has
semi apologized specifically for his
handling of the complaints that have
come through internally inside of
netflix but he is standing by the show
and to be fair to netflix it seems that
they've been quite steadfast in their
defense of chappelle and their decision
to put this on their streaming network
yes
and uh
more power to them and i
i wish more
entities
institutions companies etc
would follow that example i could have
skipped his
semi-apology you know
all about how
he he he
his his initial response didn't express
enough humanity
and that
he had he should have acknowledged the
uh the hurt
that uh
the people who are objecting
on netflix staff
uh
were obviously going through
i reject this hurt thing i mean that
that word is widely misused
uh
usually what's going on when people are
acting hurt is that they are exercising
power
and that doesn't make you feel injured
it makes you feel
utterly delighted
so it's really fun
to throw your weight around and make
your boss nervous and make him wonder
whether or not he has to take down a
show that's now number three on the
entire serving platform
uh because otherwise he's he's going to
be put in a politically untenable
position so but the larger picture is is
cheerful uh i don't get the impression
that netflix is going to take this show
down
no it doesn't seem to be the case
i suppose the flip side of that to play
devil's advocate is that and
you are allowed to be offended by
something that's intended to be funny
you are allowed to be upset by it the
question for a company is whether or not
the way that you're feeling should
impact on the product that they're
producing and ultimately in this case a
freedom of speech question because the
product they're producing is a comedy
stand-up show in which somebody in this
case dave chappelle is coming forward
with his views with his speech um so the
real question for the company and isn't
whether or not they sympathize with
perhaps some of the perspectives of the
employees but whether or not they take
that program down and in this case as
you say they're applauded because
they're choosing not to
well you know
i'm getting on in years and i'm
old-fashioned
and therefore
my answer is to go back to the old model
which was that when
something came on television that you
didn't like
you turned it off or you changed the
channel and you watched something else
there's no reason for dave chappelle to
please everyone in the audience and if
he's
hurtful to you
then you can watch something else
you know that and there's no obligation
for netflix that
to produce programming
that pleases everyone who could possibly
watch it that's an impossible model as a
business that would fail
so
some people are going to find dave
chappelle hilarious right now or last i
checked his rating on rotten tomatoes
was 96 percent
uh
so i mean most people like the special
more than i did
i wished it were a little funnier
um
but in general i am a big uh dave
chappelle
fan
and
he's an
interesting example
uh and there are many in the states
right now
of the fact that if you're a black
comedian
you can get away with murder you can
make jokes about anybody
uh the same could not be said for their
white counterparts now i'm not ex i'm
not complaining per se i wish everyone
all comedians felt that that same sense
of freedom but i am i am powerfully
relieved that there is still a segment
of the
comic comedy industry
that feels
free to
speak their mind and to make jokes and
i'm i'm very dependent on this
uh
small determined class of largely black
comedians
who are still capable of being funny
lionel my last question to you is
whether or not this canceled culture and
the segment of it
can sometimes cynically become positive
pr i can imagine that some of our
viewers may now go away and watch
chappelle's show on netflix perhaps not
having heard of him before
oh sure it works a treat it's one of the
reasons everyone is watching it because
of the controversy so uh fair enough
that's the way it works i i imagine that
sally rooney's uh new novel
is also doing better because of all the
fufura around her refusing to sell
israeli rights uh
it's all that it gave her huge amounts
of free advertising
i'm not convinced that she was being
cynically manipulative
but
if so it was a stroke of genius
and in the same way i mean yeah
chappelle
benefits from being
uh outrageous
he's deliberately outrageous and if he
weren't his audience would be
disappointed lionel thanks for joining
me
and finally what would you do without
your phone you might think that it's
only communication that would grind to a
halt but as melanie mcdonough found out
last week foamlessness impacts
everything from your ability to make
payments to being able to tell the time
she reflects on our dependence on phones
in this week's issue and she joins the
show now melanie welcome
so tell us what happened to your phone
because like a complete idiot i tried to
rum the um charger too vigorously into
my old phone and it stopped working
and um
it's a workflow and
it was going to take
quite some time to get a replacement for
some reason and so for over a week i was
without a phone
and
it was extraordinary it's it's like i'm
traveling back in time
except you're it's a solo visit back in
time because i was the only person who
was actually
not in the world where everybody
possesses um a mobile device and
it did bring home to me
the um dependence on the flipping thing
and also
i suppose the utility of it and the
sheer liberating
um aspect of
not having it
sure i can imagine in some ways it's
liberating but in other ways extremely
difficult because it seems like our
whole lives are on these mobile devices
nowadays it is terrifying and it only
dawns on you when you don't have it
uh
i mean
tiny example when you're at a bus stop
um i text a number and i find out when
the next boss is
not having that meant that i was back in
the um
in the
kind of pre-modern era when you had to
wait for a bus and you didn't know when
it was going to turn up
and um
the
more inconvenient aspect is that all my
transactions on a debit card online are
linked to a mobile phone so
my bank
has verified my visa function and that
sends a code to your phone and
once you have that code they know it's
you but if you don't have a phone they
have no way of knowing that it is you
and you don't have a way of making your
transactions and so effectively um
you can't actually do things
when you don't have them a mobile device
and for anybody
perhaps somebody is old or it doesn't
actually
function well with a mobile phone um it
must be extraordinary trying to be a
functioning member of society and um
even very basic things like paying for
my daughter's school lunches that wasn't
possible because that too was linked
to the system trying to travel if you
have an e-ticket and trying to get the
um it turns out to be impossible
to get
a ticket that is um in the e-format um
onto one where you can actually print
out your ticket and present it manually
uh there are so many aspects of life
where you're just not able to um
do things unless you have a mobile phone
i mean um
with a
courier or a taxi driver they expect you
to be able to have a mobile um where
they'll be able to call you when they're
when they're there i've got to landline
as it happens which is um pre-modern for
my children's generation but that's
actually turned out to be rather handy
you even write in the magazine this week
that your son's tutor thought you were
trying to bribe him because you handed
him an envelope full of cash
yes i couldn't actually
pay for my son's
university admissions
online and so i was trying to get one of
his teachers at school
to do it for him and so i sent him um
the um amount in cash and he just
couldn't get his head around the idea of
cash uh he thought this was some sort of
rather crude attempt at a bribe um
though
i would frankly been bribing the wrong
person
and
people are increasingly unfamiliar with
the notion of a few used drivers
so you you've spoken about all the ways
in which this was an absolute headache
but in what ways did you feel liberated
without your phone people can't get at
you um i can't explain how liberating
that is
um once you don't have a phone between
um
one um the point um at home where you've
got a laptop and an email and another
point for instance at work or you've got
a laptop and an email
people can't actually get get hold of
you and it reminded me that in the
pre-modern era
you had to be quite um organized so if
you're going to meet somebody you have
to be quite specific about where you're
going to meet them because you couldn't
just
drift around
at a venue hoping that you'd bump into
each other um for instance i was meant
to be meeting my
son at the british library for an
exhibition
i waited outside in the courtyard he
waited inside in the foyer and
for most people that scenario is
inconceivable because you you call each
other and instantly you'd have your
underwork whereas um
for us
it was just when one of us got
exasperated and went to try and find the
other harder that we actually found each
other and it used to be the case before
we had our phones we had to be quite
specific about when we were going to
meet people and where
and now we're perpetually contactable
and it's um
obviously saved a lot of inconvenience
but it is
actually uh rather terrifying that there
is no point at which we can't be got at
and um it makes everybody i think even
more febrile than they'd be otherwise
well on the other side of that as well
you actually have to show up on time to
meet your friend i will be the first to
put my hand up and say that having
access to a mobile phone means you can
very easily type in five ten minutes
late and you don't feel as bad because
at least the person knows whereas this
time they might think you're not
actually coming
um so you say in your article melanie
that you've now been lent a temporary
phone but do you think the experience
will actually make you consider going on
more phone sabbaticals voluntarily in
the future
um
well i suppose if you need a phone for
work you're not in a position to
do the digital detoxing and
obviously it's tremendously attractive
and once your family knows you've got a
mobile phone um then that's it but um
i'm disorganized and um i i'm sure that
there's um
subliminal reason why i quite often
leave it behind
so uh occasionally i i am phoneless and
i can't be contacted and um i don't
think we quite appreciate
um the
uh
sort of psychic repose you get when
there are parts of your day when you're
not contactable because at the moment we
are contactable at any time unless we
actually switch the thing off
consciously for a meeting or
for lunch or something and
i think that it has ended up with
us being perpetually on alert and i
don't think it's um
it's a good thing and the other aspect
that struck me um
because once you're without your phone
you're more conscious of the device all
around you is how the extent to which
babies are being given the bluster
things in order to
keep them quiet i mean for a baby it
dances it moves it's colorful to make
sounds but it's terrifying because we're
turning pre-verbal children
into
human beings who are dependent on a on a
device um
in the old days a baby would kind of
suck it through their second some look
at the world around it now it doesn't
have to look at the world around it
because it's got this uh wretched device
which is entertaining it cajoling it
instructed it telling it what to do i
was sitting it next to a mother and a
grandmother in um a coffee bar in
kensington the other day and um
the two of them were
looking at the child looking at this
stupid phone which had um an american
jingle telling it to wash its hands
nothing wrong with them necessarily with
washing your hands but the child was
being
turned into an automaton uh by dent of
this um device which was it was utterly
mesmerized by whereas previously it
might have made a noise it might have
been
lively it might have been a bit
disruptive um but at least it would have
been registering the people around it
instead of that at a very early age this
is pre-verbal children um and it was
only a very little girl and that she was
looking at this thing absolutely um
hypnotized by it and i don't think that
gil bill gates's grandchildren are going
to be allowed anywhere near a device um
at least until they're able to cope with
it psychically but i've got an awful
feeling that
people who are less
kind of literate about these things and
less alert to the dangers will be
turning their entire generation into
these
children who can only be pacified
by moving images by
a device by a screen and i think it's
terrifically dangerous
um it's for the likes of bill gates to
be talking about the dangers of these
things
for for little children i'm fortunate to
have grown up um in the whole era that
was pre-mobile pre-device and um
it i've got all the resources mental
resources and
um
imagination if you like to be able to
handle the world without actually
looking at a screen all the time but i
think that we're creating a generation
which is going to be unable to function
without it
melanie thanks for joining spectator tv
and that's it for this week if you
enjoyed this episode don't forget to
subscribe to the spectator's youtube
channel so you never miss out just click
the subscribe button at the bottom of
this video and tap the bell icon
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you